Film Courage: Have you ever relicensed one
of your films?
Mark Harris, Filmmaker: Yes.
We just recently relicensed BLACK COFFEE to
Balance TV.
It was on BET initially, it had been licensed
for three years on BET.
Then we re-upped for another year on BET.
And then after that license with BET we did
another renewal (well not renewal) but we
relicensed it to Balance TV.
So yes, we relicense our projects quite often.
And again, that’s how filmmakers make real
money is by controlling your content, not
giving your content away to distributors for
over three years.
And that’s therefore every time you license
your project, you make money off of it.
Film Courage: In the front-end of the deal?
Mark: Oh yes.
Most companies what they do is they either
give you something on the front end or they
pay in increments.
Say for instance if they license for a year,
they definitely give you something up front
and then they may do something every three
months until it’s all paid off.
Film Courage: Interesting.
Did companies ever try to bully you into certain
terms and steer you into “Well it would
be better if we just wait until the end of
this contract term and we will give you a
big lump sum then.”
Mark: Yes…don’t ever believe that!
Unfortunately a lot of distributors are not
honest so they give you promises that they
definitely can’t keep.
So that’s what I’m saying, their job is
to control your content because they know
it’s the only content or to license your
content for as many years as possible because
this is how they keep their company alive
and afloat by selling the rights to your film
to the different television networks and things
like that and also what they do is they call
it a 25 percent distribution fee.
Don’t ever do that.
Distributors don’t like it.
I mean…okay so this is what happens, they
say we will do a 50/50 split but we are going
to do a 25 percent license fee so if you do
a 50/50 split with the distributor but before
anybody sees any money that means that they
take 25% of whatever is made off the top so
essentially what is happening is that instead
of doing a 50/50 split, they get 75 percent
and they’re giving you 25 percent.
That’s why if you see that 25 percent distribution
fee, don’t do it at all because you’re
not making any real money.
And then another thing you have to be very
careful of is the marketing fee.
So some companies say okay we’re going to
spend 80,000 or 100,000 on marketing…hhmmm…that’s
not what happens.
I’m not talking about your big major studios.
We’re talking about the films that are made
for independent films for smaller distribution
companies.
So for a distribution company telling you
that they’re spending $100,000 marketing,
do not believe them.
They put $75,000 but they do no marketing
at all.
So they can just do a couple of posts on social
media and they can write that stuff off.
So a distribution fee for 25 percent, do not
do that deal.
If you want to do a marketing fee you want
to make sure that they give you a list of
where they’re going to market your film
at.
And not only a list but how much are they
going to charge.
Say for instance they’re to do some marketing
for inside the New York Post or inside of
a magazine but you want to know actually how
much they pay for that marketing, you want
things itemized.
Or you can cap it off and say just marketing
for $5,000.
But I wouldn’t do a deal with a company
and they’re going to take 25 percent distribution
fee or they are going to take $35,000 or they
have marketing up in there and the reason
they do that is because you see a dime you
have to recoup that marketing fee.
That’s how they are able to not pay filmmakers
because of the marketing which they never
do.
Film Courage: Did you find this out the hard
way?
Mark: I found this out the hard way, oh yes.
The distribution fee because when I was doing
my earlier films, I had to find out the hard
way it was like “What the heck is the distribution
fee?”
That means that we charge you 25 percent just
to distribute your film.
I’m like no.
So you do find out the hard way.
Marketing, you actually think that they’re
going to put marketing into your film but
they’re not.
They are going to do a couple social media
posts and that’s how they get you.
And you would never see money from your films
at all and it’s unfortunate.